[Music]
if you've been watching the show you've
probably realized that we don't have an
audience
partially because there's a global
pandemic keeping us from gathering in
large crowds
and partially because having my own show
has made me a huge diva and i don't want
any of you people making eye contact
with me
but one day we will have an audience and
because we want to know what the show
will be like
we built something introducing the
audience
bot 5000
you guys this is pretty cool invention
we hired the world's most brilliant
scientists and engineers to work on
building this machine
for the last three months now sure
they could have been working on a covent
cure but we call dibs
now here's how it works whenever i tell
a joke
this machine will simulate the exact
response that a full studio audience
would have had
laughs groans even booze better not
though
wow that's incredible how accurate is it
99.9 it's very precise can we try it out
absolutely let me just
and it's on already yeah just like that
yep oh well let's uh
try it out let's do a joke okay uh
uh according to a new report the most
stolen vehicle in america last year was
the ford f-series truck
the f stands for is my truck
whoa i know right you've got to try it
out tell a joke
uh okay um you know i heard sting turned
68 the other day
did he yeah which is funny because i've
been hearing about him
turning 69 for years
wow i guess that joke's really good i
didn't even know what could give
applause breaks
i've tested this thing hundreds of times
well maybe you should uh try testing it
with
uh some actually funny jokes
this guy's hilarious
and that wasn't even funny it was just
mean
is this an audience bot or an insult
both
that was not a joke
wasn't even a joke i was just saying
something not everything i say is
supposed to be funny audience bot
well that explains it you haven't said
one funny thing this whole evening
what the hell it can echo me why would
we even give it the chance to do that
yeah i've got the same question for the
people that gave you your own show
so funny and sharp hey
this guy should be the host of the show
i agree who's with us
yes come on he doesn't even wow
100 of the audience agrees it's
unanimous
100 that's ridiculous
this can't be how our audience would
actually react i'd way prefer to watch
this guy's version of the show than
amber's all right this robot's just
being mean to me now
why would the audience ever try to
replace me they can't even do that
unless
seth were to be like now that's a great
idea oh what the
whoa seth meyers that's right i'm
executive producer seth meyers well he
would never say that
this show's been running long enough i
think it's time we bring in a fresh new
voice to spice things up
what's your name kid wow you mean me my
name is keefer sutherland
no relation to that key for sutherland
this robot is taking a lot of liberties
well kiefer sutherland
how would you like to be a star gee
where's mr myers
me a star in the pictures oh gee i
always dreamed of this day
what's going on is this thing calibrated
for the 50s
coming to you from 30 rockefeller plaza
in new york city it's
the keeper sutherland show so basically
if we ever get an
audience there's a 99.9 chance audience
mutiny will force my show to be stolen
by an audience heckler with the exact
same name
as the famous actor kiefer sutherland i
guess so
but sounds like i get to keep my job
though
so you guys hear about this sting sting
he turned 68 the other
day i think you know where this is going
i'm just gonna turn this off no thank
you audience but
no thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you